[Music]
several homeowners in the Northwest part
of town being urged to avoid walking
their dogs late at night or early in the
morning out of caution after a mountain
lion was spotted roaming through a
neighborhood that's right well cell
phone video captured it at the
intersection of Grand Teton and Grand
Canyon Joshua peguero spoke to the
person who saw it and has advice from a
wildlife expert what was supposed to be
just returning home late from work ended
up being a mountain lion sighting for a
couple from Sky Canyon
[Music]
Brittany Avey says she wasn't scared
when she went by the mountain lion my
husband saw it first saw the mountain
lion
um and he pulled over to the side it was
just in the middle of the road Amy has
three large dogs at home she could have
been walking them at the time they saw
the large cat despite that she says it
was cool seeing it I think in a car is
the most ideal place to see something
like that I felt pretty safe and like I
said it it looked a little lost so it
was just really awesome as you can see
in the video the bottom line at one
point sits down before eventually
walking away I'd say the best thing to
do is keep our distance we showed Doug
Nielsen of the Nevada Department of
Wildlife the video that cat in the video
that that you shared with me right
toward the end she kind of pressed it
and it was getting nervous and it sat
down and kind of squatted in a leaping
position
Nielsen says it's best to walk your dog
during the day to avoid encounters with
coyotes or mountain lions if you do see
a lion don't run because it can trigger
an instinct to chase we're the ones that
can change the equation we're the ones
that have the ability to reason these
animals are going to respond based on
thousands of years of evolution and
development if you ever see a mountain
lion don't approach call animal control
or 9-1-1 reporting near Sky Canyon
Joshua peguero 8 News Now